this is a prototype of the solar
synchronizer for the 10,000 year clock
it uses a lens to focus sunlight on a
specialized piece of wire to synchronize
the clock to noon on any sunny day and
the reason we need to do that is that
the clock itself keeps pretty good time
it has a pendulum
that's rocking back and forth like most
clocks do but that has a tendency to
drift over time and we wanted a way for
the clock to naturally what's called
phase lock to a natural cycle the most
easy to use natural cycle is that of the
Sun moving across the sky we wanted to
do this without electronics so this is a
lens and this lens is set for your
latitude at at that at an angle that is
perpendicular to the Sun at your pet
your latitude and that even though the
sun's angle changes during the course of
the year that's why we made this lens a
nice long rectangular lens so that if
when the sun's high in the summer and
low in the winter we capture all of that
and it focuses sunlight onto this narrow
band right here and it has a specialized
opening that allows just a little bit of
Sun to drop through it at first and then
more and more and then all of the Sun
and what that's doing is its heating up
a piece of wire right underneath it and
it's heating up a very specialized piece
of wire called nitinol that that wire is
a special two alloy made of nickel and
titanium also called a shape-memory
alloy or a muscle wire that when it gets
up to a certain temperature it contracts
and that contraction we can actually use
as a mechanical trigger for the clock
and that shrinking gives us a mechanical
trigger which synchronizes the clock to
noon on
sunny day